tu as vu y'a personne sait pas où il est
il sait tirer
sauf si c'est un pro il ya aucun
mouvement pas une ombre à l'horizon je
vais voir de plus près et c'est tous
reçu leur dû j'ai surtout ton cul en
visu ma belle allée vivre qu'est ce que
tu vois et y associer ses touchés
c'est grave la balle est ressorti c'est
un homme à terre
[Musique]
entre position au terme d'un sniper mais
d'un gros calibre
je demande une extraction me faut vous
avez dit quoi un accent t'es pas des
nôtres tu es un sniper
il était un mec tu l'a repéré doit s qui
dira sauce est rien si j'étais toi je
commencerais à discuter à qui ce que tu
veux je veux apprendre à te connaître
il me reste une balle non non non à la
seconde où tu tousses musique est mort
c'est vrai et quand ce sera fini sa
famille ne le reconnaîtra pas tuer
déshydraté
comment ça va finir par ta mort tu vas
te vider de son sang
[Musique]
la lunette est une extension de mon âge
tu publies du gard et bly non je pète la
forme
la t 30 est une extension de mon poids
3 4 5 le fusil et une extension de
moi-même 400 peut-être 4,5
je veux éliminer celles où tu es
maintenant
[Musique]